INTRO:
Amazon just
posted their first loss in 7 years of $3.8
billion. This caused Amazon stock to tumble
14% in a single day which is their
biggest one-day drop since 2006.
This drop itself paints quite a bleak picture, but
if you zoom out on Amazon stock, you’ll see that
the stock has been struggling for quite some
time now. It’s not that Amazon has crashed 50
or 70% like Netflix or PayPal. However, they’ve
just been going sideways for roughly 2 years.
This doesn’t sound that bad until you consider
that all of their peers were going parabolic till
the start of this year. For example, since the
start of 2019, Google has outperformed Amazon by
80%, Microsoft has outperformed Amazon by 120%
and Apple has outperformed Amazon by 230%.
To make things worse, Amazon just broke down
from it’s sideways channel which has resulted
in nearly a 40% sell off from their all time
highs. And given the size of Amazon, this sell off
correlates to a $745 billion loss in market cap.
I don’t think Mr. Bezos is a big fan of this move
given that he is personally down $50 billion
year to date. So, what happened to Amazon?
LACK OF GROWTH:
Starting with the most notable concern regarding
Amazon, we have underwhelming growth figures. In
their last quarterly report, Amazon projected
that second quarter revenue would only grow
3 to 7% compared to last year. Not only is this a
smaller growth percentage than even the S&P 500,
but more importantly it’s lower than what analysts
estimated. Analysts were hoping for a $125.5
billion Q2, but with only 3 to 7% growth, we’re
looking at closer to $116 to $121 billion. This
marks the slowest growth for Amazon since the
dotcom crash way back in 2001. And at this rate,
it won’t be long before Amaon ends up posting
a full year of single digit growth figures.
Aside from nearly non-existent revenue growth,
it seems like Amazon is also struggling with
prime member growth as well. This is really not
that surprising given that basically everyone who
wants prime already has it. Also, this isn’t
some new phenomenon either. Prime users have
been leveling off for many years now, and it
looks like it’s just gonna slow down even more.
Amazon hasn’t really made this issue much better
given that they’ve been constantly hiking prices.
For example, you might’ve recently heard that
Prime subscriptions are going up to $140 per year.
But, for a significant number of Prime members,
this price hike is even more painful. You see,
that $140 number is for annual subscription
holders, but the thing is, 52% of subscribers
pay for a monthly subscription. And the monthly
subscription actually costs $15 per month or $180
per year. Now, personally, I don’t think we can
really blame Amazon for this fee increase given
the rampant inflation we’ve been experiencing, but
that doesn’t really matter. Whether Amazon’s price
hikes are justified or not, their membership cost
is simply becoming unaffordable or not worth it
for many people. And this is extremely bad news
for Amazon given that their a growth company.
I think a lot of people forgot about this
given all of the hype surrounding Tesla
stock and it’s sky high PE ratio. But, before
Tesla stock went to the moon, Amazon was by far
the biggest growth company in the world. After
all, Amazon has regularly had a PE ratio of 100
or higher for most of their history. It wasn’t
till the last few years that Amazon’s PE ratio
has consistently come in at less than 100. But,
even now, Amazon’s PE ratio stands in the mid 50s
which is extremely high for a company as mature
as Amazon. And given their poor growth forecasts,
it’s very possible that Amazon is even more mature
than we originally thought. Amazon is literally
posting growth numbers that are worse than Apple,
Google, and Microsoft, yet their PE ratio is more
than 2 times higher than any of these companies.
By this logic, Amazon stock could drop another 50%
and it would still be more richly valued than
the other FAANG companies. And unless, Amazon
is able to get their growth story back on track,
it’s likely that Amazon’s pain has just begun.
RISING COSTS:
Usually, companies like to substitute for a lack
of revenue growth with strong growth in profits,
and that’s what Amazon was trying to do as well.
Till the end 2017, Amazon’s net income was a
laughable amount compared to their revenue given
that their net margin was literally less than 1%.
This is because, Jeff Bezos preferred to reinvest
all of their excess income back into the business,
but in late 2017, he had a change of heart. He
finally decided to turn on the profit switch and
Amazon’s net income went through the roof until
now. Now, the most astute of you point out that
Amazon wouldn’t have even lost money this quarter
if it wasn’t for their $7.6 billion write off on
Rivian. And while this is absolutely true, even
if we ignore this, their bottom line isn’t looking
that great. If we take a look at their quarterly
report, we’ll see that total net sales jumped from
$108 billion to $116 billion from Q1 of 2021 to
Q1 of 2022. Yet despite this, their operating
income over halved from $8.8 billion to $3.6
billion. And it’s not like this reduction can
be attributed to any one factor either. Rather,
we’re seeing Amazon’s operating costs increase
across the board. Also, it’s not like these
increases are that substantial either. We’re
looking 10% in one category and 15% in another,
but given Amazon’s single digit net margin,
these increases add up quickly. And the worst part
is that most of this is not under their control.
For example, their cost of sales increased from
$62.4 billion to $66.5 billion. If you’re not
familiar with cost of sales, it’s basically just
the cost to produce a given product or service.
And given that the prices of raw materials and
semi conductors are increasing substantially,
this is not that suprising. Similarly, Amazon’s
fulfillment costs rose from $16.5 billion to $20.2
billion. Likely one of the biggest factors driving
up this category is skyrocketing oil prices.
Moving onto their next category, we see a very
similar story. Technology and content rose from
$12.48 billion to $14.8 billion. This can also
likely be attributed to rising chip costs which
have resulted in more expensive databases and
servers. In the end, Amazon is basically getting
screwed by inflation like all of us, but just on a
much bigger scale. As a business, their long term
goal would be to pass on these costs to customers,
and that’s likely what they’re trying to do, but
it’s a pretty fragile balance between maintaining
customers while increasing costs. Fortunately,
Jerome Powell continues to insist that we’re
gonna have a soft landing and that the worst of
inflation is behind us. The market doesn’t quite
believe him, but Jerome being right would not
only be great for Amazon but for all of us. So,
hopefully, he’s right, but even if he is right,
it would take a few quarters for stabilizing
inflation to reflect in Amazon’s bottom line.
So, Amazon will likely have to deal with
rising costs till atleast the end of this year.
PHYSICAL RETAILERS:
Aside from all these internal problems Amazon has
been facing, they’re also facing a major external
problem which is physical retailers. For decades,
physical retailers weren’t much of a threat for
Amazon. In fact, it was usually the other way
around. Physical retailers were scared of losing
market share to Amazon as they navigated the
retail apocalypse. And this was just made worse
by the pandemic and stay at home orders. However,
as things return to normal, it seems like the
innovative physical retailers are rising stronger
than ever before. In fact, online retailers lost
ground to physical retailers in 2021 and I
have a full video about this phenomenon if
you’re interested. But, the main explanation
for this shift is that physical retailers
have learned to offer the best of both worlds.
Historically, physical retailers were trying to
compete head on with Amazon by simply creating
their own websites and home delivery services
which were usually subpar to Amazon’s. However,
the innovative retailers have since learned to
leverage their locations to offer something that
Amazon can’t. This includes convenient returns,
curb side pickup, no delivery fees, knowledgeable
customer service, and a much more interactive
shopping experience. Aside from all of these
factors, many customers have also become quite
weary of Amazon’s quality. The truth is that the
vast majority of the products on Amazon are just
highly marked up items from AliExpress/Alibaba.
And usually the quality is just not that great
especially compared to items that you can
find at physical retailers. Personally,
I’ve found this issue to be most prevalent amongst
cheap electronics and specifically dongles. Since
the start of 2021, I’ve gone through 3 USB C
dongles and 3 Display Port to HDMI convertors
all from Amazon. They simply stop working within
3 to 6 months. Considering all this, it no longer
seems like online retailers are just going to
completely wipe out physical retailers. Rather,
it seems like they’ve reached some sort of balance
and that things are going to be relatively stable
moving forward. And while this is great news for
physical retailers, this is terrible for Amazon.
AMAZON’S DARK HORSE:
Up until now, we’ve mainly discussed Amazon’s
retail business, but the truth is, a significant
portion of their business has nothing to do
with retail. While 84% of Amazon’s revenue does
come from their retail business, virtually all of
their profits come from their cloud business, AWS.
In fact, last quarter AWS accounted for 100% of
Amazon’s operating income given that Amazon.com
was a net loss both in North America and
internationally. This is really nothing
new given AWS has been holding up Amazon since it
was created in 2006. But, over the past few years,
it did seem like Amazon was finally starting
to become independent of AWS as they posted
their first profitable quarters. However, all of
that progress was wiped out with rising costs.
And this leaves us with a serious question, how
long can AWS just keep propping up Amazon? Using
AWS to fund Amazon’s growth was a genius strategy
in the early 2010s. But, it’s starting to get
old now that we’re 16 years in. Fortunately, it
doesn’t seem like AWS revenue is slowing down yet,
but it’s only a matter of time until
any business starts to stagnate.
And Amazon’s continuing dependence on AWS
isn’t the most assuring of characteristics.
FUTURE OUTLOOK:
Despite all these concerns, I’m personally still
optimistic about Amazon’s future. Here’s the
thing, Amazon has decisively won ecomerce and
yes they’re a monopoly. 56.7% of all e-commerce
sales happened on Amazon in 2021, and while
online retailing is starting to stabilize,
I don’t think Amazon will be losing their
dominance within this sector anytime soon.
Something else to note is that Amazon just
announced a 20 to 1 stock split and this would
be their first stock split since 1999. At current
prices, Amazon’s post split price would be just
over $100. And though, stock splits don’t actually
change anything fundamentally about the company,
I think a stock split could attract a lot more
retail investors. I know some of you will argue
that the introduction of fractional shares
has made stock splits completely useless.
And technically this is true if we just focus on
stock returns, but I mean who actually wants to
own a quarter or a third of a share. Also, trading
derivatives on Amazon is currently unreasonably
expensive for most retail investors. A stock split
will substantially help with derivatives pricing.
Combine this new retail interest with a
fundamental recovery from Amazon and I think
it’s just a matter of time until Amazon recovers
to its all time high and makes new all time highs.
I liked Amazon stock when it was $2900 per share,
so I really like it now, but that’s just what I
think and it’s definitely not financial advice.
Would you guys invest in Amazon right now? Comment
that down below. Also, drop a like if you’re
hoping that this stock market pain ends soon.
And of course, consider checking out our
international channels to watch our videos
in other languages and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.